[Música]
queremos la jugada italiana del
Ministro Mario Draghi agradable al Parlamento
reconstruir de qué son
nacional entre la crisis que provocó la gente en
movimiento de 5 estrellas
la crisis es que el pasado cuando el
movimiento 5 estrellas son votar una moción
con financiación de su propio gobierno y mucho
sasi caliente en el resto pasó que
Dragones obligados a plantarse presagia
al renunciar reccia sabe que después del café es
sido serchio pero tal el salón dentro de 6 ne
Se aumento en noticias de valdera solo
giulio levratto analistas internacionales
Candidato a doctorado en ciencias políticas
en la universidad de génova gracias a giulio
prestar con otra sensación geomática
frase 24 mwana magnana mis reglas ya
entonces estrella de la baustelle esa dosis es necesaria
políticamente en Italia la cuenta previa que
en resumen, diez comunes y el impuesto de crisis de boer
Este
El blog obviamente es bajo que la vida nocturna.
del movimiento 5 estrellas sobre la novedad
política realmente renovación alquitrán el auricular
un gobierno al que se marcha después
el impacto particularmente fuerte en
spoleto que presenta el ministro ante el
ministro dragones y su discurso dei
viola
sofá renova sia de pacto
confianza dentro del gobierno i los
partidos políticos lo que va seguirá ahora
suma y discusión dentro del senado e
de la cámara de diputados que podrá
terminar con un renault va alla con
finanzas del gobierno o con y de
gamos si lo es
la posibilidad de un gobierno provisional o
en caso de que el rodillo les de y lo
contrario serio y lección sobre
probablemente en tonos de la mano derecha
realmente me encantan los dragones
puri se mantuvo presa morse y último
oral safa no manita para poder
reconstruir el gobierno sean cuales sean
mantente limpio bauer es como lo digo
pronta selección si en Italia
lo que pasa es que es
que el movimiento 5 estrellas a su video
la política corre, puedo determinarme a mí mismo y
un regalo enorme para el deporte i para
los partidos politicos grecia en italia
que ahora mismo si algo en esto
se formaron en el descuento electoral o robot
contra todo pronóstico de gharian para ganar
y su selección abre uno
particularmente la escena política
delicado en tiempos de crisis
economía política
e de defensa y a la que nos enfrentamos
ayudando internacionalmente
Entonces, ¿qué paso es realmente Giulio?
dentro de esto que es gobernante el
amapour que si lo digo a estas alturas
¿Por qué el movimiento 5 estrellas gas abad?
y conocer y se muestra con las finanzas
contra los dragones de mario marcando 6 grahams
Apenas conozco al gobierno tal como es.
italiano
que el movimiento 5 estrellas en el partido
que el sol no deja nada como salida
la ciencia siempre distorsionada por morrison
del horizonte ideológico cloro y
Salcido sobre el punto de que la fuerza y ​​​​que seriedad
reflejo sobre la flexibilidad hacia arriba
La adaptabilidad al mismo tiempo ha aumentado.
punto debilita y fue que pasando por
a position la otra ialiano se nel
curso de ciencias con partidos
totalmente diferente y angela hacen una
pérdida de credibilidad del partido y en
relación con sousse y lectores del partido
momento honesto si vs lugares de video si ves
dividido entre un frente gobernador liga
movimiento que apoya a mario dragons chi
Él sabe
los que aún conserva el hermano parásito
señor una posición tradicional con
referencia al asombro
anti sistema e
antipolítico
original del movimiento iasc 5 estrellas
intactos están tratando de escalar
del movimiento del gobierno a la máscara e
El movimiento y su última selección.
ministro de estado tv culo si te tengo te tengo
fuertemente raid abandonó su cursus
consentimiento de su apoyo popular
electoral si te aseguro que no puedo 20
no venus un rollo protagonizando el
próxima administración
Julius Tam y las cabras señalan lo que es.
la importancia de mario dragons y nel
Gobierno y política italianos
Estoy listo porque entonces cuando esté ahí
asiento efectivo soberano nuncio il
presidente serchio mattarella y mismo
el palacio sé por qué mattarella rezza
solar no son dragones los llamo si no
intención como un por qué re con conmovedor
ant.ser gobierno a unas elecciones si el
pieza y mario dragones oritana política
italiano
luego mario dragons y por supuesto en uno
referencia a nivel europeo y nacional
internacional sobre la autoridad política y sobre
esa consistencia
tiempo de puntuación de posición en relación con
conflicto en Ucrania e
legítimo por reconocimiento
internacionales son características que
un gobierno debe tomar en un momento de
redefinición del desequilibrio económico
político y militar y en todo el mundo
en el mismo nario y en una persona
carismático con mario dragons italia
corre, logro perder una tirada de juego
en un papel del protagonista en un
Momento ruso para la redefinición dl del
desequilibrio
kabul internacional ¿cuál es el
rector principal que actualmente ostenta es
el gobierno italiano a un ritmo de
una selección
La sepia se está reorganizando y no se toma.
en Italia eso en adelante fue claro pero corre
un vecino para el ministro italiano si ahí
cosa que asi son en luego mario
dragones diano matan la intención del oeste era
construcción
aquel municipio del cual está arriba de aidos
posibilidad ahora en caso de que arrastre
no te quedes con la confianza que te dirán si si, eh
voto de confianza uno es en uno nuevo
gobierno técnico que acompaña a ria e
italia astra el siguiente selecto sia
principio honesto del próximo año
primavera el próximo año
El
Momento no, no, él no se alinea con un di amoni.
ombres particulares y él lo encontrará
canal en caso de que fa lección rosa en
gobierno de beber chandon de la figura as
suerte prominente solar de matteo
salvini que si lider de la liga norte y
todo de giorgia meloni islas que sla
líder del partido y romano de
Italia que en la fiesta y que aguanta
origen y en el movimiento social italiano
¿Quién fue? Es una fiesta inspiradora.
inspirarse en un fascista de ello
claramente y Wattner un peso en y en
Desconexión italiana a nivel
especialmente internacional
considerando que el marcador a la derecha en
Italia no se lava del estanque.
siempre posición de santos europeos también
alianza atlántica pro rusa que
posición pero se moverá